dylan c is going to the mound for his
16th start
looking for his seventh win the era very
respectable 3.81
also 96 strikeouts and 75 and two thirds
that's very good the control is getting
better only 32 watts so here are the key
matchups nelson cruz who hits just about
everybody in a white sox uniform has
hurt dylan's seats josh donaldson on the
other hand with a couple of walks but no
hits max kepler with a home run and he's
three for eight so those are the guys
that
were obviously going to kia
in the air to right field
gavin sheets
in his second major league game makes a
catch
and one down so let's welcome josh
donaldson to the plate no longer raining
precipitation but it is raining booze
swinging a fly ball into left field he
drops the bat will stare this one into
the seats beckett goes and gone
donaldson homers again in chicago once
again in the opening inning the twins
dugout is jumping around donaldson
flipped the bat stares that one into the
seats and the twins take a one-nothing
lead in chicago doesn't say much this
time
except celebrates with his teammates
high fives to play inside that jubilant
first base dugout high fastball a little
bat flip and this ball is crushed what's
a villain if not somebody who does it
again the next day right
one two is right there a breaking ball
sends larnick away and two down
over looking comfortable on the big
league mound
making his sixth start of the year he's
got some deception he's a very tall guy
he throws strikes
and there's a ground ball hit right to
simmons and anderson's gone on the
second pitch as was the case last night
two and two to mankata
and the strike thrower gets a quick
second out as well
we've seen that from over
white sox didn't chase much in his debut
pitch count ran up a little bit but
he just lives in the strike zone and the
o2 pitch a swing and a miss strike three
high fastball at 95. so ober comes out
with a shutdown quick one two three
first after one twins are coming up on
top one to nothing 1-1
broken bat one hopper to anderson he'll
step on second throw to first double
play
pretty easy 6-3 twin killing and it'll
bring up brian goodwin over motions a
pitch hit in the air deep right way back
there it's going to go
to tie the game brian goodland
with his second home run
and it's one to one he got a reprieve
lynn he did get that same curveball
didn't miss at that time only went 382
but it got out of here in a hurry you
could tell looking at kepler that this
one was either well over the wall or off
the top of the wall here's vaughn the
number eight hitter playing left
1-2 fly ball out in the deep left center
gordon tracking he's at the wall it's
gone
that is a two-run blast
andrew vaughn gives the sox the lead
good timing what a beautiful job by
andrew vaughn keeping his left shoulder
closed on what appeared to be a high
slider
he made sure to not pull off of the
pitch
he got out around it and hooked it out
of here pitch away hit it to left center
field got his whole backside into it but
when you're in the kind of struggle that
jose abreu is in sometimes you just have
to pretty much sell out for one pitch
two and two
jose to right field kepler back at the
track it's out of here
just a second home run this month for
jose abreu
and he rides it just over the yellow
line
for the third sox home run tonight
the home runs just like you like them
lynn nobody on but they add to their
lead as abrayo just leaned on a fastball
out over the plate very similar to the
one he did not catch up with in this
same advantage it's a fastball it's up
and away and it's out tonight it's not
going to take a great deal to get it out
of the park and jose just barely got it
over but over it went first and third
two down 302 again ground ball right to
tim anderson the shortstop he'll step on
second
they force carol off and that's it for
the minnesota twins
midway in the fourth you can hear its
runners at the corners the sox looking
for more we have seen a recent vintage
that you really never have enough right
andrew vaughan on a slider in the air
center field gordon is back at the track
to bring it in
goodwin tags from third and scores to
make it a sac fly and the sox add
another one and andrew was very close to
his second home run he didn't get the
good part of the bat on that it was a
towering fly ball that just kept on
drifting sets and delivers
lifted in the air
left field should be routine and that is
it and the innings over
they push one more across on the sac fly
rbi by vaughn his third ribby tonight
two on for grandahl who's lined out and
struck out 2-2 home
fly ball well hit center field
gordon at the track that ball is
gone a home run
waiting for gordon's reaction to see if
he had the ball
it's a three-run homer for grand all
it's 8-1
and the sox have a fourth home run yes
takes it out of the ballpark opposite
way gordon goes up it's in the glove for
a moment and literally he throws it out
of the park so he had the catch
and then threw it out of the park when
the glove hit
the wall gavin sheets one for two he's
three for six as a big league hitter
deep to right center
number of his career
enjoy the trip gavin sheets
we said this team needs to hit some home
runs and they have responded with five
of them tonight just look at the smile
on his face gives you an idea about
exactly what it's like when you get your
first look
this floated to center tim anderson's
got himself a hit
here comes run number 11.
the parade continues
and a 2-1
hit high in the air left field as
nelson cruz will watch this one fly out
of here
there's his 18th home run of the year
and now
it's 11-2 chicago here's grand all he
cranked a three-run homer in the fifth
fly ball well hit to right there's
number two for grand all over the
bullpen
a two-run homer it's 13-2
that one's certainly a no-doubter i mean
he got just about every bit of that
[Music]
danny mendick it's short why not tonight
everything's coming up white sox
that was quite a play
that had some top spin on it and it took
a little extra quick bounce on him and
for him to go ahead and smother it with
a dive and then spin on a knee 360.
chanting jose
for ruiz
line to right
and that'll do it
gavin sheets hauls in the final out on
the night when he hits his first major
league home run